alors lukla c'est la première fois que
tout le monde parle de vous donc on va
vous faire une interview première fois
le premier souvenir mon premier souvenir
lenny kravitz
voilà j'ai rencontré à 16 ans dans un
bar vous avez parlé
ah oui je vais parler j'ai une grande
photo là un beau portrait pierre oui
premier mensonge strato un très très tôt
très tôt
je devais avoir 6 enfin si l'on traite
première balle très tôt si vous avez des
stats et mensongères le de quoi ce que
j'ai fait mais je pense même à ma grande
soeur m'avait surpris en tresserre du
bisou à un garçon je n'ai pas non non
non pas encore normal mais voilà et puis
ça se faisait pas dans la famille
version première fois que vous avez fait
pleurer votre mère quand je suis parti
de chez moi que l'âge saison première
injustice dont vous aviez été victime
je sais moi j'irai le décès de mon frère
mais je sais pour moi c'est une
injustice midi fabre voilà comme les
jours à l'école très bien ouais ouais
jamais bien les caunois suis contente
oui premières vacances la tanger avec
mes parents oui couleur de leur robe
les jours du mariage de ma soeur j'ai eu
droit à une très jolie rang pour les
coups de foudre à 20 ans ricains
quelqu'un voudrait beaucoup plus gênant
première déclaration d'amour ces mêmes
lentarteur premier baiser sur la bouche
j'ai fait très tard mon premier baiser
sur la bouche
j'avais 15 ans oui je suivais les
copines parce que tout le monde avait
fait rose en fils moi j'avais encore
rien que c'était avec la langue
non c'était sans la langue et avec la
langue et avec la langue
ça a été bien plus tard ouais précoce
première fois avec un garçon première
fois avec un garçon 21 ans 2e fois moi
ça continue première fois à troyes
jamais à 4 pour les ruptures première
rupture première grande rupture
ap ap j'arrivais à 23 ans
ça reste un an et demi avec le cdur
bastille dur oui c'était dur j'ai
souffert personnellement j'ai surfé se
le dire franchement maintenant si j'ai
vraiment souffert
j'ai eu un moment de spleen terrible
écrit tu m'a pas répondu
je téléphonais théo rester sur répondeur
c'est vrai et ça m'a pas plu du tout et
après quand j'ai su que tu avais un
petit enfant j'ai vraiment eu mal mais
maintenant quel effet ça te fait de me
revoir
bailly écoute j'aimerais bien qu'on se
reprenne un peu plus tard et puis qu'on
ne peut pas recommencer à zéro
ce serait bien que ça c'est pas ça se
discute
j'ai une situation très confortable et
je passe dans l'émission d'ardisson
c'est comme tu sais quand tu voudras
c'est quand même marrant vous vous
retrouvez ici tous les autres est
bizarre c'est fou cas c'est la vie c'est
le mektoub
c'est incroyable ça retient son bilan
c'est insensé et elle n'a pas changé
un bon j'ai un peu vieilli j'ai fait mon
point ben non premier bêta premier
pétard ya pas longtemps mais j'adore ça
voilà le balsa mal dans les villes
téchiné isabelle loi
entre chez vous quelques